today on the matt walsh show discovery
just announced a new show about
cross-dressing children called
generation drag the corporate media will
continue grooming and sexualizing kids
no matter what it costs them also biden
thinks the economic devastation he's
causing is hilarious the dhs secretary
tries to defend his agency's new
ministry of truth and in our daily
cancellation we meet a trans queer
latinx neurodivergent public theologian
what do any of those words mean we'll
find out today maybe all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
so do you have an account with coinbase
or if you're thinking about opening one
as well then you want to listen to this
with an alto crypto ira you can trade
crypto like bitcoin you can also avoid
or defer the taxes you can get into
investing in crypto and do it in a tax
advantage retirement account alto's
crypto ira is the easy way to get crypto
into an ira you could trade all you want
without the tax headache it's real
simple to do create an account in just a
few minutes invest with as little as 10
there's no setup charges and what that
means is that this is easy to do it's
cheap uh it's something as simple so
simple that even i could do it and
figure it out secure trading 24 7
through alto's integration with coinbase
there are 80 plus coins available
including bitcoin ethereum cardano many
other coins as well available multiple
ways to fund your account you can make a
cash contribution you can transfer cash
from existing ira or rollover an old
401k again all very easy to do open an
alto crypto ira account with as little
as ten dollars just go to alto ira dot
com slash matt that's a l t o i r a dot
com slash matt go to alto
ira.com matt
so last month discovery media merged
with uh warner media to create a new
media conglomerate creatively called
warner brothers discovery you'll notice
how all the people in media who are so
concerned about elon musk taking control
of twitter rarely batnai when these
giant corporations merge or buy each
other out or come together through other
means of corporate copulation and form
these giant monopoly behemoths
that is they aren't concerned until they
start losing their jobs as was the case
over at cnn when the newly formed warner
brothers discovery started cutting off
the dead limbs starting first with that
rotting useless piece of lumber called
cnn plus the goal is to you know bring
everything all of the various
smaller streaming services owned by the
company under uh discovery plus and hbo
max
now after the merger and the merciful
euthanizing of cnn streaming service
warner brothers discovery needs some
successes you know it needs some hits
uh needs to get some attention needs it
needs it needs hits is what it needs and
it apparently believes that it has just
that with a new series just announced
debuting on discovery plus in a few
weeks called generation drag
this is a reality show produced by tyra
banks and uh revolving around
five child cross-dressers as they
prepare a bit for a big drag show in
denver which invites quote teen queens
kings and non-binary performers ages 8
to 18.
now the children featured on the
discovery plus show seemed to run that
age gamut from
very young to simply young and all of
them them of course too young to be
involved in the liberal west version of
baka bazi discovery released the trailer
for this abomination on friday uh the
comments if you go to youtube are
disabled i wonder why
you can actually see why they're
disabled when you watch the clip let's
watch this
welcome
to the pink palace my lovely friend
i first discovered dragged at 13th
i didn't know what it was but i knew i
wanted it
put on the wig and the makeup and i'm
someone completely different i'm so
pretty
my drag name is vanessa shimmer and she
is just a force you can not reckon with
how do i parent a child that wants to do
drag
i never expected drag to be a part of
our lives oh my god these are so cute
these are problems i never thought i had
to prepare for
what i love about drag is the glitz and
the glam
i'll pause it here for a moment because
i want to answer the question that the
abusive mother asks albeit rhetorically
she asks how do i parent a child who
wants to do drag and her answer on how
to parent the child is to uh not parent
him at all to instead allow him to be
swept along by whatever forces are
influencing him and simply stand by
while he's used and abused in this way
although that's probably a far too
generous interpretation of this woman's
role and motives given that she's not
only allowing her child to do drag but
also putting him on television it's
pretty clear that the forces influencing
the child and driving him the crossdress
are at least partially his parents
as the horror movies tell us it's coming
from inside the house
there are a couple more points to be
made here i think um some of which
require us to unfortunately watch a
little bit more of this which uh we will
do now watch
noah and i'm transgender
have you talked to mom and dad about
your pictures
what do you think of taking those photos
down did constant remind her that i had
to pretend i was a boy
do you think a mom would ever want to
watch me do drag how do i explain this
to my child that she doesn't fully
accept novella
making friends has been a hard thing for
me to do when i'm becoming nemo
become more confident let me make sure
you are appropriately fluffed
this transition has been difficult for
them but
they try and that's all you can ask for
it's important for kids to understand
that they're not alone
so my mom started draguton kids and
their families are coming from all over
the country where we get to be our true
selves oh god
this is happening
this is a place of love and support
because we need that in this world
this is me
and you better like it
[Music]
[Applause]
now one interesting thing that you see
there when you watch this is that uh it
seems like every child
featured in the show
actually has what appears to be
a father
in the picture
and you notice one there the father
himself is wearing the drag wig
now that's probably not a coincidence
i'm sure they they selected for that
because they didn't want to
uh you know
they didn't want to promote the
stereotype that boys who get involved in
this kind of thing oftentimes don't have
fathers so they they selected families
where there's a father there in the
picture
but that only emphasizes the fact that
there are many different kinds of
fatherless homes and when we talk about
the fatherless home epidemic
oftentimes that that boils down to the
statistics of fathers who are physically
not in the home but if you're just
looking at that you're not getting the
full picture because the actual epidemic
is much
much larger than that
and there are plenty of homes where
there's a where there's a father
physically present like his he's a
living breathing organism taking up
physical space within the home but he's
not present in any other way he's not
spiritually present he's not emotionally
present he's not psychologically present
he's certainly not present as a source
of of discipline and direction which is
one of the one of the primary things
that children need fathers for so these
are all fatherless homes even if they're
um their fathers
quote unquote are physically there
now the child at the end there says uh
this is me and you better like it
but tragically he's wrong on both counts
because he's been led wrong he's been
led astray this is not him when he's
dressed up in girl clothes and prancing
around on stage for the enjoyment of
predator adults who should all be in
prison
that's not him
what is presented on stage is a
rejection of everything that comprises
his authentic self a rejection of his
masculinity his boyhood his childhood
his innocence
all of that is sacrificed and he's not
choosing to sacrifice it because he
doesn't know what he's giving up or what
the consequences will be the adults in
his life are sacrificing it for him
now the fact that this show exists
and um is produced by one of the largest
media companies in the world and um
one of the most famous
and mainstream models in the world tyra
banks is involved as well
and that they're putting this out there
at a time when there's such intense and
eminently justified backlash over this
kind of thing you know that all proves
yet again of course beyond any shadow of
a doubt that there is a conspiracy to
groom and sexualized children warner
brothers is planting its flag here they
will promote
the grooming and sexual abuse of
children no matter how much outrage it
provokes
they're even willing to lose money to do
it
you know last week we had the um
the clip from good morning america from
a few years ago when they were talking
about child drag performers and they
brought a child
drag queen quote unquote on stage
and that was done at a time
as evidenced by the fact that hardly
anyone noticed when they did it
that was done at a time when when the
media could do stuff like this and um
and get away with it
now you do this there's going to be
outrage
and they know that
so they're willing to
deal with that they're losing willing to
lose money to do it that's how important
it is to them
and that's a that's also an important
point to be to be made here and to
realize but there's another point i want
to make as well
consider this um
child
beauty pageants events where young girls
are caked in makeup and paraded around
on stage
those are dying out all across the
western world there's been even a push
in some countries including in this one
to ban the pageants outright but even if
they haven't been successfully outlawed
yet they're certainly and thankfully not
nearly as popular as they once were
there is wide mainstream agreement that
it is inappropriate to get your daughter
involved in something like this
worse than inappropriate it's
exploitative and abusive
this is one of the reasons why the
horrible tlc show toddlers and tiaras
was cancelled back in 2013
and even people who won't necessarily go
that far in describing the pageants
maybe won't call them abusive and
exploitative uh even most of those
people will admit
that it's it's controversial at any rate
you can go to pretty much any left-wing
media outlet and find articles that have
been written denouncing these kinds of
pageants
certainly if discovery which owns tlc
had announced last week a revival of
toddlers and tiaras
there'd be widespread outrage over the
decision and it would be outrage echoed
by the left wing and in the mainstream
media
after all why do you need
to dress
um little girls up like fashion models
and kick makeup on their face
and then send them out on stage to strut
around is this how little girls should
be spending their time
the answer of course is no and most
people seem to agree
these days
anyway that the answer is no
and yet
if you take little boys
and put them in dresses
and cake them in the makeup
suddenly many of the people who said
that this sort of thing sexualizes
little girls are okay with it
more than okay they celebrate it in fact
tyra banks herself on her short-lived
talk show 10 years ago
addressed the issue of child beauty
pageants and treated it as a
controversial subject she apparently was
against it
now she's producing a show about drag
pageants for boys
how can this be explained
have these people suddenly decided that
what was sexualization for girls isn't
for boys
no
the answer is not that they don't think
that these drag shows sexualize kids
it's that in this case
that's exactly what they want to do
you know sexualizing girls is wrong they
say
but sexualizing boys for the sake of
promoting the lgbt lifestyle
well that's an entirely different matter
as far as they're concerned
and that i think is the real point
behind all of this
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know one thing we know about the
left is that they hate everything that
is good and true in the world and also
everything that's delicious which is why
they're waging this war on meat and look
when the supply chain inflation caused
meat prices to soar uh their response
isn't to
solve the supply chain inflation to tell
you that this is the perfect opportunity
to switch from juicy delicious
nutritious meat to uh you know
something called lentils or veggie
patties or even worse bugs outlets like
time magazine tell us eating bugs is the
solution to all of your problems
and you know the people telling you to
do it aren't doing it themselves of
course as always but they want you to
eat bugs um that's why recently i've
come to the realization of something
it's not enough to not eat bugs you have
to be anti bug eating and that requires
action against the bug eating movement
big bug the best way to do that is to
eat more meat so i've decided to double
down on my meat intake and i'm inviting
you to join me as well with good
ranchers for a limited time good
ranchers is offering two pounds of free
american wagyu beef when you go to
goodranchers.com walsh enter promo code
walsh checkout if you're worried about
the supply chain or inflation increasing
the price of meat over time the solution
is not lentils the solution is to uh go
to good ranchers so please don't let the
vegans and bug eaters win we need to
double down on eating meat literally two
pounds of free wagyu burgers and zero
inflation what are you waiting for use
my code walsh or visit goodranchers.com
welsh if you don't buy the meat in-house
um then tell the person who does to grab
your two pounds of free american burgers
today before they're gone that's promo
code wallshot goodranchers.comwalsh
so the white house correspondent dinner
was uh back this weekend
a time for the ruling class to get
together and have a good hearty laugh
over how badly they're screwing up the
country
and biden apparently in a in a moment
that will
you're going to see this mom you've
already probably seen it a million times
you're going to see it a million more
times especially as we head into the
into the midterms i mean this is going
to be this is going to be featured this
moment in particular on 100 different
ads and then never mind as we get into
2024 i mean this is a this is a moment
tailor-made for attack ads from the
other side um here's biden
having a good laugh
about um how badly he's screwing up
america let's watch
i think ever since you've come into
office things are really looking up you
know gas is up rent is up food is up
everything
no it really has been a tough first year
for you mr president
yeah now
the one thing about this is that uh when
that joke is made
i'm not exactly sure what the right
reaction is
because if biden had sat there and
looked angry or something then you know
that would be the story too i guess they
can't take a joke but but uh whatever
the right reaction is it's certainly not
to laugh
even if it is kind of an impossible like
there's there's no winning right there
when you're sitting there at an event
like this
and uh someone makes a joke about how
your
inflation and everything
panned to you and your reaction there's
no good reaction but that only speaks to
that's not a defense of biden
that's exactly why this event should be
happening in the first place
because it's an event where there's just
no there's no right way to go about it
and especially
when there is a food shortage and there
is inflation and people are suffering
economically and so many other ways
that the ruling class is going to get
together and and uh just have a nice
time and you know show off their uh
their luxury and wealth and all the rest
of it
so why would they do it it's it's not
that they're you know one thing i've
heard and i think this is wrong
i've heard from some people criticizing
this some conservatives that it's like
they're these people are oblivious
they're out of touch there's another
expression you hear quite a bit
and i actually don't think that that's
correct it's they know how this is
perceived
they know that the average person who
sees them all in their tuxedos having a
having a banquet laughing about these
things that are very serious i mean
inflation to the people in that room
inflation is a joke because it doesn't
really affect them that much because
they're all rich
um trevor noah is somehow
a rich wealthy comedian
which that's a different subject but
i'll never understand that i mean i've
yet to and i've given him a shot but
trevor noah he's almost as bad
as like female feminist comedians
i've never heard i cannot think i mean
if someone has an example let me know
but i can't think of one good joke i've
ever heard him make not one
but regardless um this doesn't affect
any of them so they can have a lot they
can have a nice laugh about it are they
out of touch
do they not do they not realize how this
is perceived by the rest of us
well no they they know they just that's
the point it's not that they don't care
either it's that's the point they're
quite aware
of how it's perceived and that's the
point this is about them
establishing their place atop the
hierarchy it's the same thing with the
oscars
there's always these questions about
well why were they still at the oscars
don't they realize oh these out of touch
celebrities once again no yes they they
realize how it seems they realize how
it's perceived
you're you have a four-hour
ceremony
on prime time television to just talk
about how great you are and award
yourselves and pat yourselves on the
back
they know how it seems to the rest of us
and they're happy about that because
again it's about us it's about
reestablishing the hierarchy it's about
them saying to everybody else we're up
here and you're down here
and if you're resentful and all that
that's fine that's just you being
jealous of us
we're okay with you as the peons being
resentful and jealous
so i think that's
crucial for us to understand about this
later on joe biden himself got up and
did his own
stand-up routine and let's uh listen to
some of that
but i'm not worried about the midterms
i'm not worried about them we may end up
with more partisan gridlock but i'm
confident we can work it out during my
remaining six years of the presidency
and folks
i'm not really here to roast the gop
that's not my style besides there's
nothing i can say about the gop that
kevin mccarthy hasn't already put on
tape
i know
[Music]
at the same
at the same time a lot of people say the
republican party is too extreme too
divisive too controlled by one person
they say that's not your father's
republican party
ronald reagan said mr gorbachev tear
this wall down today's republicans say
tear down mickey mouse's house
and pretty soon they'll be storming
cinderella's castle you can be sure of
it
but republicans
seem to support one fellow
some guy named brandon
he's having a really good year
and i'm kind of happy for him
hmm
i mean the brandon joke was okay it was
that was that was uh
that was you know i give that a c plus n
not too bad it's like slightly
self-deprecating
but yeah you got to throw that in you
got to throw in this slightly
self-deprecating joke um the other thing
is like that was for the most part
um cringy and embarrassing and um
nothing more cringy and embarrassing
than the comment about six more years
and you could tell even though they
applauded in the audience you know no
one
no one in sitting in that room feels
that way about i mean these are the same
people remember
who a couple of weeks ago
when obama showed up in the white house
they left joe biden to just wander
around by himself
standing alone sat in the corner so
that's how they feel about joe biden
well they had to applaud oh yeah six
more years sure sure gramps
um cringing embarrassing yes but at this
at the same time he did whatever meds
they pumped into him so that he could
basically be coherent for minutes at a
time but keep in mind this was not just
that was a minute clip but
he spoke for like a few minutes in a row
and was basically coherent for that
entire time
so i guess you give credit to whatever
meds they put them on because they they
pumped them full of something
and this is the point we've gotten to
now with joe biden where um
if you can see a clip of him speaking
for one minute and making sense
and not just randomly wandering off the
podium or turning his back to the
audience and talking to the wall or like
if you could just see for one minute
standing in front of a microphone and
speaking and making basically making
sense
that's impressive you're impressed by
that
and this is the president of the united
states and we're impressed by that
oh good for him you spoke for a minute
that's an improvement
this is the president we're talking
about
my god a little more political news a
new book says that camilla harris is uh
here's a shocker
bit of a diva in the white house
apparently who would have thought uh
this is a new book that's
i believe is just released and let's
watch this interview on nbc kamala
harris uh felt disrespected here's one
anecdote you have hair's worried that
biden's staff looked down on her she
fixated on real and perceived snubs in
ways the west wing found tedious when
harris walked into a room the white
house staff did not stand up the way
they did for biden the vice president
took it as a sign of disrespect what was
astonishing here is apparently there was
a meeting about this yes the the chief
of staff to uh kamal harris telephoned
the west wing and told a senior advisor
in the west wind divide
the vp has noticed this and
she uh would like folks to stand staff
members to stand when she enters the
room
this pulls back the i think the the
curtain on what this white house is
really like the tensions are deep and
they are real between the vp's office
and the west wing obviously the public
image is is what it is but they this is
an ongoing challenge and what is
hovering over all of this truck yeah is
24. so clear is biden gonna running it
and if not is it going to be vp harris
that is the mood music hanging over the
entire democratic party right now as our
biden's poor numbers
um
by the way that's from a book called
this will not pass which uh is is being
released i think tomorrow
and um
i i did just go check just just out of
curiosity on amazon and uh right now it
is
it did surge one spot ahead of johnny
the walrus so johnny the walrus was
number one overall in amazon for four
days and right now it's at number three
as this will not pass just passed in
front of it and i could first of all
consider this to be in a
an attack on my identity as a children's
author and an assault on my
psychological well-being to be just at
number three on amazon so you can go to
johnnywalrus.com
and make sure that we remedy that
but in any case that's some of the what
we hear in the book is uh about camille
harris being a diva which which is you
know that's
exactly what any rational person this is
exactly the kind of thing that a
rational person expected to hear when
they selected camilla harris
and now democrats of course this is not
any kind of
uh great political insight to say that
democrats are in
trouble for 2024 because joe biden
might claim that he's going to run again
and maybe he thinks that he will
and maybe he actually will
but they have to know that that's just
not gonna work i mean the idea of joe
biden look at what he is right now we're
impressed with him stringing a sentence
together for a year you know for a
minute rather uh certainly not a year
and now imagine him at the age he's
gonna be 82
running
with the claim that he's going to be in
office until he's 86
that's just not going to work but the
other on the other hand
that seems more desirable than having
camilla harris because that's how
unpopular she was this is what happens
if you take someone who got like 0.1
percent in the polls and you make them
the vice president
because you're worried more about
identity politics and uh you've decided
to take the affirmative action approach
this is what you end up with
now one more piece of political news um
speaking of people who have no shot in
2024 i got to play this for you asa
hutchinson is the eunuch governor of
arkansas
who perhaps not surprisingly supports
turning little boys into unix eunuchs
of his many sins as the governor of
arkansas he
as you may recall
vetoed a bill that would have made it
illegal to chemically castrate little
kids and sterilize little kids
um and he was not in in favor of that
bill because he thinks the kids you know
it should be okay to do that to kids he
had an announcement of his own to make
on cnn let's watch a bit of that
you spoke at the politics and eggs event
in new hampshire a traditional stop for
any a presidential hopeful are you
seriously considering running for
president
uh i am but you've got to get through of
course this year but that's an option
that's on the table and that's one of
the reasons i was in new hampshire and
you had secretary mayorkas on and the
border security is such an incredible
issue that's what the kind of thing that
i'm passionate about whenever
you look at we need to have title 42 or
some equivalent to it secondly we've got
to go after the cartels in a more
vigorous fashion
and then thirdly we've got to support
the states and in the role that we play
so there's much to be done there i care
about those issues and so yes i'm going
to be engaged this year and hopefully
beyond that
even if president trump runs you will
run
consider running his his his uh
candidacy won't affect yours
no it won't i've made it clear i think
we ought to have a different direction
in the future and so
i'm not aligned in uh
with him uh on some of his endorsements
but also the direction he wants to take
our country i think he did a lot of good
things for our country but we need to go
a different direction and so that's not
a factor in my decision-making process
ace hodgins thinks he's going to be
president thinks he has a chance
um that
i have a better chance of becoming
president like actually a much better
chance and i haven't i have zero chance
i have zero chance but much better
than this guy
um there is
simply no
path for republicans like this anymore
and by the way there hasn't been
um there hasn't been one since romney
ran and lost
um
or rather since mccain ran and lost
there hasn't been a path for republicans
like this kind of republican
the milk toast uh
establishment republican who's just as i
say that what i think the word for them
really is the speed bump republicans who
maybe will lay down in the road and just
try to stop
not stops
momentarily slow the progress
of of leftism but a lot of times they
won't even do that much
there's no path anymore there hasn't
been for years
and there certainly is not now
what does he think i'd like to see his
internal polling when he's sitting down
with his advisors what what exactly are
they telling him
where is your audience
where's your base exactly
doesn't exist i can tell you that all
right this is an interesting story from
cbs we're going to get out of politics
before we go back to it
in a moment but a little bit of history
here it's a story from cbs news
says um when mexican police found a pile
of about 150 skulls in a cave near the
guatemalan border they thought they were
looking at a crime scene and took the
bones to the state capital turns out it
was a very cold case it took a decade of
tests and analysis to determine the
skulls were from a s from sacrificial
victims killed between
um 900 and 1200 a.d
so this is a crime from cold case about
a thousand years old
this is according to the national
institute of anthropology and history on
wednesday
state capital and the institute said
believing they were looking at a crime
scene investigators collected the bones
and started examining them
the police in 2012 were being stooped at
the border area around the town of
frontera
in
where this happened has long been
plagued by violence and cartels and
everything and so that's what they
thought they were looking at
uh and pre-hispanic skull piles of
mexico usually show a hole bashed
through each side of every skull and
were usually found in ceremonial plazas
not caves
now they say usually because
they find a lot of skull piles that's
kind of a troubling thing when you could
use what you could say a statement like
that well the the skull piles are
usually found with big holes punctured
in them and uh they're usually found in
certain areas where we know the
ceremonies were conducted but in this
case they found him in caves and what
does that tell you
um it's because this is
where you know the aztec empire was
and um
this is what they did they they
uh
believed that in order for the sun to
rise in order for them to continue
existing they had to continually appease
their gods with human sacrifices
and this happened not just in one
location but across the entire empire
and thousands and thousands of people
were killed
slaves were taken
oftentimes children oftentimes women
and they were killed in various
different ways
of course the primary method of
execution for the aztecs anyway for
human sacrifices was to
pin them down to a stone slab and cut
open their chests and pull their hearts
out
and then they would cut off the people's
limbs and um
the the kind of the trunk of the now
decapitated butchered person would be
rolled down the temple steps and the
limbs would often times be eaten by the
uh by the the priest now i bring all
this up
not just because i'm trying to shock and
horrify you but because this is history
and this is what happened
before
the spanish showed up before the
conquistador showed up
and but that's an event that we're
supposed to we're told mourn this is a
terrible thing when the conquistadors
came the europeans came and they
conquered
you know the new world
and we're supposed to mourn this and
we're supposed to continually apologize
for it also
even though none of us around today had
anything to do with it
not that i'm
not that i begrudge you know i'm fine
taking the credit
um
for something like that
because as it turns out you know this is
what the conquistadors were up against
if you can imagine and you can't because
none of us can
you are you've already sailed across
an unknown
sea
and you land somewhere
and you really don't know where you are
now it's impossible for us to even
conceptualize this because we
you know we have gps we have so
everything
you know our our perception of the world
is completely different we because we
know what the world looks like
and you could pull out your phone and
just connect with a satellite and it'll
tell you how to get anywhere in the
world
they didn't have that back then
and
so they had no idea where they were
um you're landing on a plot of land you
don't know how big it is you don't know
what's what's there you have no idea and
they venture inland
and the first thing that happens is they
come across these
big temples and pyramids and they climb
up and they go inside and and oftentimes
the place is
drenched in
blood and it smells like human flesh and
there are decapitated heads and
and limbs all over the place and they
found this everywhere they went
and they're
vastly outnumbered
by this enormous empire of warriors who
this is what they do they just capture
and kill people
and they manage to uh conquer this this
uh this empire
extraordinary story
it's a story of courage and heroism and
something we should all be grateful for
thank god i mean this this civilization
that butchered women cuts cut the hearts
out of children
by the thousands thank god they were
conquered
that's what we should be saying
all right going back into politics
briefly here um the dhs secretary
appeared on cnn over the weekend to
defend
um the ministry of truth that they have
put in place what they're calling the
disinformation board
and uh the dhs secretary says that hey
everything you're hearing about it it's
all a bunch of uh this is just
conspiracy theories don't worry about it
because he says you you can we can trust
them
we can trust them let's listen
will american citizens be monitored no
guarantee that well so what we do we in
the department of homeland security
don't monitor
uh american citizens you don't but will
this board change that no no the board
does not have any operational authority
or capability what it will do
is gather together best practices in
addressing the threat
of disinformation from foreign state
adversaries from the cartels and
disseminate those best practices to the
operators that have been executing in
addressing this threat for years
okay well then there's nothing to worry
about i mean the people that are in
charge of this they've told us that we
can trust them they're not going to
monitor americans how often have we
heard that from government agencies
oh we don't we don't monitor
americans
except when we do but other than the
times when we do we don't
now he's also asked about nina jankowicz
who is the left-wing activist who's
going to run this disinformation board
the ministry of truth and he says that
uh nothing to worry about there either
because she's totally neutral and very
trustworthy let's listen to that
republicans are criticizing
your decision the administration's
decision to choose nina jankowicz to
lead this disinformation board they say
she is not somebody who is neutral your
response eminently qualified a renowned
expert in the field of disinformation
absolutely so
would you be okay if donald trump were
president if he created this
disinformation governance board or if it
is in place and he wins again in 2024
that he's in charge of such a thing i
believe that this working group that
gathers together
gathers together best practices make
sure that our our work is coordinated
consistent with those best practices
that we're safeguarding the right of
free speech that we're safeguarding
civil liberties i think is an
extraordinarily important endeavor
before i let you go i'm sure you uh have
heard that kevin carthy now the
republican leader who hopes to be
speaker if republicans take over in
november uh will consider impeaching you
oh he gives reaction that but i'm i
assume he's opposed to being impeached i
don't know now we know that what he said
he said nina jankowicz is is neutral um
we know that that's not true because
she's on the record with her she's she's
ideological she's a leftist
uh very open about that she's been on
the record about that in the past we
also know
even though she's supposed to be a
foremost expert in disinformation i
don't know how exactly you become an
expert in disinformation in a way
everybody at cnn are experts in this
disinformation i suppose experts in
disseminating it anyway
um
but so that's one of the ways that we
know that she's not neutral is because
we know she's a leftist
but also we know that she's not neutral
because
she is we assume
um a human being
now
if she was some kind of robot that might
be different but even then if she was a
robot then she would have been built and
programmed by somebody which means
also not neutral because every there is
no neutral human being on earth
that doesn't exist
every human being has a worldview
has uh
has opinions
has a perspective
has some kind of
ideological commitment
even if it's half-baked and
self-contradictory and all the rest of
it which it is for a lot of people
especially on the left but still
there are no neutral people does not
exist
and when he says that she's totally
neutral we we know that that's a lie
but the reason that he says that is
because
the only way
that something like this could possibly
actually work
is it was actually being run
by neutral people
we would need to be able to trust
that the disinf what their labeling
disinformation actually is and that they
don't have any other
motivations
and that they're not politically
invested in any way whatsoever
like in order for it to work we would
need to be able to trust that but we
can't
because no human being is neutral
and that's the whole point really
that that's why we the government can't
do things like this
because we're relying on them
as political actors
to be the arbiters of what is true and
what isn't
what is valid information and what isn't
the fact that no human being is neutral
is the whole point
and that's that's what makes this so
dangerous
and of course even though he says that
yeah well if trump was in charge the
government and he was running the
disinformation board
um
i'd be fine with that he says that but
of course we know that's also not true
whatsoever
um one other quick thing before we get
to the comment section i want to put
this up on the screen this is uh let's
go to nine clip nine here this is um
a tweet from this is a guy who works at
microsoft
and his name is justin nelson
his handle is the geek diplomat
kind of tells you what we're dealing
with and he puts he's got an image of
his positive kova 19 test because he's
still taking covet tests apparently and
this is this captured
rage crying this morning
two years of isolating and keeping my
toddler safe and i get infected with
kova 19 at a mandatory team off site
even while wearing a kn 95 mask
now my toddlers are exposed this isn't
over
we need to immunize under fives now
hashtag immunize under fives now it's a
hashtag calling for you know injecting
kids under the age of five
imagine being a man
[Music]
who not only rage cries i don't know
what a rage cry is
i know what rage is
i do have some experience with that
but crying because you're enraged
um i'm not a lot familiar with that but
ra rage crying number one is the first
problem and then doing it over a mild
illness because you got a cold and then
announcing it to the world shamelessly
and we can't expect from the kind of guy
who rage cries over a cold
i don't know if he's married or not i
mean he has a kid
you got to feel bad for the wife just
think about that ladies
how would you react if you went into the
room
and your husband
is is crying because he has a cold
and then you and then you said to him
what are you crying and he said i'm only
crying because i'm angry
uh that's
how do you go forward as a as a woman in
that situation knowing that this is the
kind of man you're married i'm sure it's
not news to her
but anyway the kind of guy who rage
cries i assume we probably cannot uh
obviously we can't rely on him to have
any sort of introspection but if he was
capable of introspection then he might
start thinking to himself well wow um
i have
completely my life has has revolved
around this for two years i have
sacrificed two years of my life
just to avoid getting a cold
and i've and worse than that i've
sacrificed
um my
child being able to live a normal life
so that he doesn't get a cold and and
then and then it happens anyway
so an introspective person first of all
would not have gotten to this point in
the first place but if they did would
stop and think well you know maybe the
lesson here is
that i should just be living my life
because these kinds of things are going
to happen
maybe when he's done when he wipes the
tears away and he's done rage crying
maybe he'll start thinking about some of
those things let's get now to the
comment section
[Music]
evox pop says just two questions how
soon can this ministry of truth and its
board be disbanded
and who has the power to do it well uh
the only people that could do it are
this is another government initiative
government agency government board
whatever if the government's doing it
then the only people who can stop it are
also in the government
and um our only ability to do anything
about it
is to try to vote people into office who
will
put an end to it
um
but that's
that's that's the issue here is um
when republicans are in control
of the executive branch can we rely on
them to disband the ministry of truth
you know i think if ron santos becomes
president then that's exactly the kind
of thing that he would do and he's
proven that with the way that he's
governed florida but um a lot of
republicans know i wouldn't trust them
to do it
because here's the thing
a ministry of truth just like every time
the government expands and gets into a
new area
it always means of course more power for
the government and the people who are in
the government especially people running
the government
and having your own ministry of truth
means a lot of power
and so you need people in office who are
willing to
sacrifice their own power who are
willing to say this is an enormous
amount of power that this particular
thing gives me
and i'm willing to give it up
um
most republicans have proven over the
course of many decades that they are not
actually willing to do that which is why
even though every republican campaigns
on shrinking the size of the government
none of them i mean literally none of
them have done it
so far
because you run the government and the
bigger the government is more power that
you have
so that's uh that's kind of the catch-22
here that means that there's just a very
small select number of republicans that
we can trust to take a radical action
like that and
like i said small small select group
let's see jax says
love his point about going to college
after high school i served a two-year
mission after high school and my college
experience so far has been a lot better
for me than it would have uh been if i
hadn't done that i feel a bit more
mature and understand who i am better
than if i went to college straight after
high school
um
that's exactly
the point and you're not gonna find
very many people who wait a few years to
go to college
and
regret the fact that they didn't go
right at the age of 18.
meanwhile there are a whole lot of
people who regret the fact that they
went to college right out of high school
i know there's not a lot of regret in
the other way but there's a whole lot of
regret um
in the other camp
let's see another comment says one week
ago i attended the hodge twins comedy
show in california it was hilarious they
opened it up for q a and the first
question that was asked of the twins was
are you guys part of the sweet baby gang
and they didn't know what it was i
yelled out sbg for life our conservative
community is growing so rapidly now
because the left is so insane
love the mw show
they didn't know what sweet baby gang is
i once again feel attacked by that
but
i love the fact that we are we are
growing the cult is growing
and anytime you could put somebody on
the spot who who will have no idea what
you're talking about you should
definitely do it
um
let's see lance says love that walsh
comes swinging for ben multiple
after multiple speeches in a row lol oh
he doesn't need the help but we are a
team here at the daily wire that's and
that's definitely not the case
with every conservative media outlet so
you can't take that for granted but i
think it is here
um
whiteout says matt i recently found out
that my parents enjoy pineapple on their
pizza this has scarred and devastated me
emotionally how do i confront them of
their insurrection against my well-being
look as a dedicated contrarian and i get
these comments with questions about
pineapple pizza all the time
um and as a contrarian i i've decided i
guess that i'm going to become an
apologist for pineapple on pizza i don't
even like it that much i don't hate it
as much as many people do
but
i am now officially in favor of
pineapple on pizza just because i'm sick
of people complaining about it so much
so i'm on your parents side in fact you
know what i haven't done this in a while
but you sir are bad from the show
you know last week my lgbtq plus
masterpiece of a book johnny the walrus
became the number one best-selling book
in america and uh is still at least in
the top five and of course the deranged
leftists saw this is a great opportunity
to be even more deranged amazon quickly
followed up my great success by banning
the books advertisements after a leaked
video revealed their infantile employees
holding some sort of cry session over
the book which is quite hilarious uh so
i'm celebrating a little bit this
wednesday may 4th i'll be doing a live
book signing at 7 pm central on youtube
brett cooper host of the comment section
will join me to moderate an audience q a
as i answer your questions live and sign
copies of the greatest children's book
ever written the only way you can get
your signed copy of johnny walrus is to
become a daily wire all access member
using code walrus when you do so you'll
not only receive a signed copy of johnny
the walrus but you'll also get your uh
get our iconic leftist tears tumbler
which really goes with johnny lawrence
because there's so many leftist tiers
you need a tumbler for them so you got
to get all that together if you haven't
gotten your copy yet now is the time
head to dailywire.com
subscribe to get your new all-access
membership using code walrus to receive
a signed copy of johnny the walrus right
now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
for our daily cancellation today we turn
our attention to an article from one of
our local outlets here in tennessee
called the tennessean in a recent piece
the tennessean extends an invitation to
us that um none of us asked for or
wanted
headline is
meet nashville's trans queer latinx
neurodivergent theologian
now you'll notice already that this
headline is nominally six words long and
yet after the second word nashville it
takes a three-word detour into utter
gibberish and doesn't return to reality
and words that exist in the dictionary
until the end with the word theologian
everything in between is abject nonsense
this gives you an idea as to what to
expect as we venture into the text of
the article itself it begins
robin henderson espinoza is the only
nashville-based trans queer latinx
neurodivergent public theologian that
they know
wait
that who knows
that they know
sounds like there's a sentence cut off
here or maybe the author of this piece
had a stroke while they were typing but
it turns out that of course the they
refers to robin henderson espinoza who
despite having three names is only one
person but still goes by they anyway and
it continues
i don't know anybody like me henderson
espinoza who uses gender neutral
pronouns said in an interview
yet it was only recently when henderson
espinoza 45 got to know their better
self or rather got to know their self
better
got to know their self better
okay such as the diagnosis that they are
on the autism spectrum amid this
eventful period in their life henderson
espinoza also made time to write
reflections about their personal
experience and its connection to larger
socio-political events which they turned
into a book henderson espinoza's new
book body becoming a path to our
liberation released on tuesday
somehow i don't feel a threat from that
book to johnny the walrus i don't think
that i have to worry about that making
it into the top 10.
um i must again though point out uh here
that the the correct
gender neutral pronoun for an individual
entity
is it
so if you're really neither male nor
female and yet you're a single person
then you are an it
but robin just like every other supposed
gender-neutral person doesn't want to
use it because that sounds dehumanizing
which it is but rejecting the binary of
female and male is by its nature
dehumanizing as you are rejecting the
very human nature which declares that
there are only males and females
these people want to have their
dehumanized cake and eat it too
um robin says that she and i i think
this is a female but i'm taking a bit of
a shot shot in the dark here um she is
unlike anyone she knows incredibly
unique i don't know anybody like me
now that's obviously the point of all
this the accumulation of meaningless
identity labels is a narcissistic
attempt to present yourself as more
complex more interesting deeper more
profound than the average person
and yet it has precisely the opposite
effect but she's not done claiming
labels
it continues henderson espinoza an
ordained baptist minister who has a phd
in philosophy knew for many years that
they were transgender but didn't explore
what that meant to them until 2017 when
they moved to nashville from california
henderson espinoza found a vanderbilt
physician who was overseeing henderson
espinoza's hormone therapy then in 2018
henderson espinoza learned that they're
on the autism spectrum it never occurred
to me that my brain worked differently
henderson espinoza wrote in their new
book i realized that my socialization in
the church and academy had been through
neuro-normative people who didn't
understand my body or my mind and had
curated such a disconnection from my
body
wait
if you didn't
if you don't identify as either male or
female then what are the hormones
supposed to achieve exactly
meanwhile robin addicted to the
self-satisfied high she got from
accruing the labels trans non-binary
latinx
decided to go back for another hit
adding neurodivergent to the list
as this happened with so many other
things the category of mental illness
has now been fully subsumed by the lgbt
alphabet crew
this is why lgbt activists will so often
list their mental health conditions as
if the conditions themselves are sexual
identities
and like sexual identities
mental illness has been made into
something trendy you know desirable
another way to set yourself apart
the made-up term neuro-normative has the
same scoffing tone and dismissive ring
to it as the made-up term cisgender and
that's the other thing about all of the
obsessive labeling that leftists do to
themselves
while labeling themselves
they also put labels on the rest of us
that we did not choose or agree to or
consent to
cisgender is not a term that any
so-called cisgender person chooses for
themselves it's a label that trans
activists place on us
now god forbid we label them in a way
they don't like
but you know they can label us all they
want
those are the rules they want us to play
by anyway but i refuse
also note in that last segment again
the sheer volume of absolute certifiable
nonsense especially the last sentence
i realized that my socialization in the
church and academy had been through
neuro-normative people
who didn't understand my body or my mind
and had curated such a disconnection
from my body
curated a disconnection from your body
how is a disconnection curated
how can someone else curate your own
disconnection whatever that means
what in the hell are you babbling about
well robin does quite a lot of babbling
it turns out
this is common of leftists generally but
especially those who identify themselves
as pastors and theologians
those two labels as it happens are the
most absurd of all the titles robin
gives to herself as evidenced by this
clip of robin um henderson esposa
originally posted to twitter by a group
called q christian fellowship which says
in its bio that its mission is to
cultivate radical belonging for lgbtq
plus people and it achieves this
apparently through incoherent prattle
like this listen
the not yet is the imaginal space of
becoming
the not yet is is in the space of a
realized utopia
the not yet is the christian message
that we must embody in critical and
creative ways
to steward a narrative that calls us
into being human with one another again
that is the kind of hope
i want to invite us to embody
that is the kind of queerness
that i hope we can practice
one that reimagines language and
practice and narratives
that can be midwifed and stewarded
through the imaginal
that
is hope to me
that is the kind of power
i think we have as a collective of
believers
of doubters
of christians
as those who are becoming
so this is like the leftist version of
speaking in tongues because no part of
what you just heard qualifies as english
neither does it qualify as christian i
mean it is religious no question but
this is not the christian religion
you're hearing there
um just to quote one section of it she
says
that is the kind of queerness that i
hope we can practice one that reimagines
language and practice and narratives
that can be midwifed and stewarded
through the imaginal
oh okay
now
if you listen to that and you hear all
the big words and think well maybe i'm
just too stupid to understand what she's
saying then you're having exactly the
reaction that people who speak this way
want you to have and you're also wrong
you are not too stupid
your failure to understand gibberish is
not a shortcoming on your part
this is just how smug leftist academics
speak because for one thing they would
rather dazzle you with their faux
intelligence than actually communicate
like normal human beings
they don't want to be understood
they want to be admired
when it comes to leftist ideas in
particular this is especially the case
they hide behind this impenetrable
fortress of scholarly sounding
because along with wanting to impress
you with what it usually turns out to be
a pretty middling intellect they also
want to disguise their true meaning
such as there actually is any true
meaning at all whatever they're trying
to say if they're trying to say anything
they prefer to keep it safe locked
inside a you know a box of gibberish and
buzzwords
the hope is that you'll just nod
confusedly and go along with whatever it
is they want you to do or whatever
direction they want to take you
they want you to scratch your head and
shrug your shoulders and say uh okay
sure let's be uh
stewarded to the imaginal space of
queerness uh sounds good
what they don't want you to do is stop
and say wait a second what exactly are
you trying to say
can you speak like somebody who isn't
suffering from a severe confusion
concussion and just put it in plain
english for me
they don't want that because if there is
any meaning underneath all this nonsense
it's something quite horrifying
something that they clearly
don't want you to see or understand
and that is why finally robin the
neurolatinx transbinary divergent
theologian
is today canceled and we'll leave it
there thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. joe biden belly laughs at your pain
during the white house correspondence
association dinner america's most famous
leftist intellectual praises donald
trump and the italian government turns
feminist i'm sad to say check it out on
the michael knowles show
you